was für eine woche endlich kriegen viele
deutsche einen neuen frechen stufen
schnitt und on top noch einen stufenplan
für lockerungen angela merkel hat sogar
ihre geliebte incidents 35 aufgegeben
wenn die in diesen konferenzen gar
nichts mehr zu melden hat wozu sitzt sie
da überhaupt noch fragt man sich na ja
es wird gelockert weil die menschen
nicht mehr können das ist riskant aber
wir flankieren das ganze jahr mit impfen
und tests gut impfen klappt noch nicht
so aber das mit dem testen auch nicht
doch nicht mehr lange meine damen und
herren denn eine task force soll jetzt
ohne ende schnelltests nach deutschland
holen eine task-force geleitet von zwei
lebenden legenden den besten der besten
von abdi scheuer und jens spahn das
ganze wenig ausdenken task force der
sofas fonds merkel fragt sich also wer
holt mir den test karren aus dem dreck
guckt sich am kabinettstisch um und
landet bei scheuer und sparen waren alle
anderen gerade pinkeln
wir brauchen nicht noch eine
arbeitsgruppe wir brauchen viel mehr
tests kein wunder dass die nerven blank
liegen haben sie das gehört was der
söder im streit um geld dem olaf scholz
an den kopf geworfen hat du bist hier
nicht der könig von deutschland du bist
nicht der weltenherrscher der sollte mal
nicht so schlimm wie ich gucken der
scholz brauchen ja auch gar nicht so
schlampig zu grinsen das schlampige
grinsen was schauen sie denn so schlumpf
hier er solle nicht so schmutzig
aussehen er sollte nicht so schlimm ich
lachen hören sie auch so schlumpf sich
aus zu sehen sie schlumpf gesicht was
mich aber am meisten runter schlumpf
meine damen und herren
er ist gut fünf prozent der deutschen
schlümpfe sind aktuell geimpft
gleichzeitig liegen millionen impfdosen
bei uns ungenutzt im schrank sonne voll
blamage wirklich es folgt die
untertreibung des jahres so schnell wie
möglich impfstoffe an die menschen
bringen und wir glauben dass wir hier
noch steigerungspotenzial
ja das glaube ich auch meine mehr luft
nach oben geht ja gar nicht
steigerungspotenzial wir müssen verdammt
noch mal aus dem quark schluss mit
bürokratie terror oder bedenkenträgerei
in israel impfen sie bei ikea ikea
es gebe so viele orte wo man ganz
beiläufig impfen könnte so nebenbei ja
natürlich meine die amis impfen in
stadien oder im drive thru ja warum
nicht
mann her es gibt doch bei uns neuerdings
diesen boom
denn wenn irgendwo eine schlange
rumsteht vom bäcker oder so dann kommt
halt sonntag profi und im stil leute ja
wohl mal machen nicht immer warten bis
der arzt kommt ernsthaft warum können
wir hier das nahe legen denn nicht
einfach machen zb astrazeneca ohne
altersbeschränkung zu lassen
er kommt jetzt aber wochen zu spät weil
man immer erst die ständige
impfkommission fragen muss oder den
ethikrat oder die jury von the voice
kids keine ahnung alles unnötig
kompliziert apropos haben sie die neuen
lockerungs regeln eigentlich verstanden
das heißt ich mache öffnungs schritt 2
und sehe dann nach 14 tagen was hat
meine incidents erbracht ist sie stabil
oder sinkt sie sogar
da kann ich die nächsten öffnungs
schritt gehen und wenn auf dem weg
zwischen einem eröffnungs schritt und
den nächsten die incidents von 100 also
die verdopplung von 50 passiert dann
muss ich wenn das drei
aufeinanderfolgende tage so ist an dem
zweiten darauf folgenden tag dann den
schritt wieder zurückgehen
genau nach drei tagen den zweiten
darauffolgenden zurück sehr logisch das
wäre dann die dienstag an die waren ein
schaltjahr oder einigen wir uns auf es
wird gelockert dominante mutante hin
oder her
und seien wir auch mal dankbar für das
positive die friseure haben wieder auf
offensichtlich jetzt schon das
medienereignis des jahres
manche tv kollegen waren nicht nur
begeistert sondern regelrecht erregt
lauwarmes wasser shampoo dass ein
massiert wird
das sanfte kratzen des kampfes an der
kopfhaut das metallische klicken der
schere haareschneiden fühlt sich im
dauer lockdown seltsam intensiver geil
waschen schneiden rubbeln bin gespannt
auf seinen beitrag wenn die pucks wieder
aufmachen also haare wieder schön und
noch wichtiger
hoffnung auf urlaub und reisen gut
ostern wie es aussieht wohl noch nicht
aber im sommer mit impfpass das kriegen
wir doch wenigstens hin
rechtzeitig vor dem sommer oder oder zur
eröffnungs diskussion gehört auch der
digitale impfpass wir bereits in israel
eingeführt wurde
in deutschland ist der erst ab dem
kommenden jahr vorgesehen
spahn sprach allerdings von einer
vorübergehenden lösung bis dahin die
aber erst gefunden werden müsse wie ich
mir mein gott die briten haben dank
schneller impfung einen wasserdichten
öffnungs plan die buchen gerade für den
sommer ohne ende reisen und wir gucken
in die röhre
das ist nicht hinnehmbar meine damen und
herren wenn er wir haben doch auch eine
handvoll geimpfte die müssen jetzt ran
geimpfte 80 jährige deutschland braucht
euch ein letztes mal
denn der engländer darf im sommer wieder
nach mallorca heißt auf dieser liege
liegt dann ein krebs roter eu verbessern
und auf dieser und dieser und allen
anderen auch nur du kannst politische
geländegewinne noch verhindern
genau wie damals also buch jetzt male
aber ich wollte nach tirol schnauze
marschbefehl mallorca sonst wird aus der
schinkenstraße die hem street und dem
megapark sind die queen auf mallorca ein
bett im kornfeld also wir zählen auf
dich in deutschland wird auch am
ballermann verteidigt
[Applaus]
das ist der spirit ja wenn man das alles
zusammenfasst vor allem für jens spahn
unseren gesundheitsminister kommt im
moment tatsächlich dicke impf debakel
zurückgenommene test versprechen und
jetzt auch noch die sogenannte den
affäre
sparen war im oktober bei einem privaten
cdu spenden den er in leipzig und zwar
genau einen tag vor seinem positiven
corona test kurz gesagt man möchte
gerade wirklich nicht sein
pressesprecher sein sowie albrecht
humboldt der uns jetzt live zugeschaltet
ist der humboldt ist nicht leicht oder
haben sie bloß auf politik ist so ein
dreckiges undankbares geschäft neulich
war der jens noch der goldjunge der
kommende kanzler jetzt gehen alle auf
die andere straßenseite meine kollegen
und ich sitzen in der bundestags kantine
am katzentisch bei den parteilosen bei
frauke petry er klar dass es hart und
was ist jetzt mit der denner geschichte
ja der jens war in leipzig bei einem
dinner wo spenden für seinen wahlkampf
gesammelt wurden und am selben tag hat
er leider dass hier im zdf gesagt wir
wissen vor allem dass die haupt
ansteckungskette gibt nämlich beim
feiern beim gesellig sein zuhause privat
oder eben in der veranstaltung auf der
party ja und das war eben stunden später
privat auf einer party veranstaltung
gesellig feiern steinig team mein gott
er hat da keinen angesteckt und alle
haben masken getragen ja massen aber das
war doch ein essen
dafür gibt es inzwischen längst hightech
lösungen und der griechische gastronom
hat eine maske mit reißverschluss
entworfen
so kann jeder problemlos gleichzeitig
gyros pommes und salat essen hier in der
beweis
mich überzeugt wo wir gerade bei masken
sind was sagen sie denn zu dieser
spiegel recherche dass jens spahn auf
empfehlung von csu lobbyisten völlig
überteuerte masken von der schweizer
firma gekauft hat amigo affäre reloaded
es hieß doch immer kauft masken
außerdem kam die empfehlung von monika
hohlmeier das ist die tochter von franz
josef strauß was das was soll man da
machen mit der csu liegt du dich nicht
an die drei gefährlichsten gangs im land
geplant bandidos und amigos wenn die
sagen kauf masken dann kaufst du masken
das bundeswehr rüstungs amt in koblenz
hat damals gesagt die sind zu teuer
ich sag noch mal war das so lustig ist
der bundeswehr den erfindern des geld
verbrennt man die dinger zu teuer jens
spahn ich so jetzt habe ich keinen bock
mehr
sie stellen uns ja da wie wie
vollidioten jens spahn ist doch nicht
der watsch'n august der nationen kommen
sie mal über was die bundesländer
verbocken kommen sie da mal ja aber auf
uns da haut man drauf nur weil wir ein
vielleicht zwei mal nicht optimal
eingekauft haben chef die schweizer
haben uns drei millionen neue masken
geliefert a sehr gut
leute ihr müsst doch mal vor dem
bezahlen auch in den karton wein co
das haben wir uns schon wieder verarscht
albrecht reimold
[Applaus]
immerhin hat man sich in berlin nach den
neuesten amigo affäre endlich zu einem
lobbyregister durchgerungen wenn auch
mit allerhand schlupflöcher so was mich
persönlich an der endlosen corona krise
besonders deprimiert über die probleme
von bestimmten gruppen diskutieren wir
ständig andere fallen mehr oder weniger
durchs raster
die kommen nicht vor das müssen wir
ändern mit einer weiteren folge von die
vergessenen der kuba-krise teil 3412
studierende
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum online pro
seminar studium 2021 unter diese hätte
ich mal eine friseurlehre gemacht hier
ein gemälde von 1843 mit dem titel
student und gemütlichkeit heute wohnt
derselbe student aus geldnot wieder bei
seinen eltern im kinderzimmer und an
harry potter poster maximale demütigung
für meine generation war das studieren
das gelebte klischee morgens um 16 uhr
frisch in den tag starten 18 uhr wäre
die vorlesung aber es ist auch halt karl
marx lesekreis und annikas dabei was
will man machen
die vorlesung läuft nicht weg wenn
studierende heute überhaupt noch freunde
treffen zwischen den lock downs geht
keinen joint herum sondern das kontakt
nach verfolgungs formular ein wort das
genau so lang ist wie die wartezeit auf
den impfstoff der in studierende sind
den arschbacken gruppe 4
auch finanziell die ganzen nebenjobs
brechen weg ist aber nicht so dass der
staat die leute allein lässt in der
krise kommt die kanzlerin sogar
persönlich im internet vorbei und
spendet trost was haben sie jetzt noch
in der im studium zu tun noch prüfungen
oder warum können sie nicht in die
schule gehen dürfen sie nicht aber
bisschen studieren können sie jetzt
trotzdem noch oder wie wie viele
hochschulen hat das saarland
welche hochschule war das jetzt noch
einmal beziehen sie bafög
sie sind unsere zukunft wir wollen
natürlich dass sie stark aus dieser
krise hervorgehen
wer merkel vorwirft dass das nur warme
worte sind im muss man sagen die worte
waren nicht mal warm
allein bis oktober haben studierende
rund eine milliarde an krediten
aufgenommen und für überbrückungshilfen
muss man nachweisen dass man unter 500
euro auf dem konto hat finde ich richtig
bonzen die 600 euro auf ihrem konto
bunkern um mein geld zu baden die möchte
ich nicht unterstützen
2 du muss nachweisen dass du arm bist
wegen großer nicht einfach so für viele
haben seien ja einfach sein lifestyle
und dann gibt es erstsemester die sind
eingeschrieben haben sie uni aber noch
nie von innen gesehen
doch in einem höher
zwar haben die beiden noch nie gesessen
zu zweit und auf abstand draußen vorbei
laufen sich an der mobilen mensa auf
eine suppe verabreden das ist aktuell
das maximum an persönlicher kontakt
möglichkeit politiker sollen sich mal an
ihre eigene lustige uni zeit erinnern
sogar bei den physik nerds gab es partys
mit dj und allem drum und dran
haben sie selber aufgelegt nee ich habe
ich war ja bardame aber naja wir sind
wieder gar nicht in der ddr konnte man
barbara auf besser studieren
erinnert euch doch mal eure eigene
jugend als ihr noch träume und ideale
hatte sie zb warnte damals nicht dass
sie später einmal fast alleine
deutschlands digitalisierung verhindern
würde
oder hier lockenkopf olaf scholz konnte
nicht wissen dass aber im kanzlerin 2021
mal einen tollen dritten platz holte
bolls boulder und zum schluss ein quiz
was wurde aus diesen sympathischen
gabler drogendealer oder b
bundespräsident auflösung nächste woche
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein like dallas ich hab die schnauze
voll
loslassen abo da